the issue with Carrie Lake and with any
anyone involved in this is that every
single person in politics save like I
don't know five ten people okay to be
fair maybe 50. uh they're cowards
they're all cowards I'm I've I've been
uh I feel like DeSantis is a letdown I
feel like he is too weak Carrie lake is
strong Trump is strong I like that there
are a decent number of strong people in
Congress Matt Gates standing up to Kevin
McCarthy was absolutely fantastic
Marjorie Taylor green Lauren bobert
despite the fact Roger Taylor green was
in favor of Kevin McCarthy she's stood
up on a lot of issues but I look at
these these these court cases and these
judges and everyone's just like oh man I
don't want to do this I don't want to be
involved so what I guess I would say is
you know aside from this story I feel
like a big thing that's being revealed
right now is just how cowardly so much
of our society and and government is how
many individuals are
probably why people voted for Trump
probably why people like Carrie Lake